house republicans yesterday opposed a
measure to form a commission
to investigate the events of january 6th
they want to have a january 6 commission
to investigate because because
we haven't investigated enough there
aren't enough investigations already
there are as far as i can tell like
dozens of investigations
into this um into you know people
trespassing in capitol hill
federal we get local dc's all
all levels of government various
agencies
they're tracking these people down and
anyone they can find
any little old grandmother who you know
crossed the
cross the threshold into the building
for 15 seconds uh they're gonna they're
gonna
they're sending swat teams to our house
to put her in prison for for 17 years
but it's not enough we need more more
investigations
as far as investigating the uh rioting
that happened
and terrorized our cities for months on
end and in which
uh dozens of people were killed and
billions of dollars was was
damage was inflicted no they're not we
don't need to investigate
that so obviously uh
this should be opposed republicans
should oppose it
and not every republican did i think 30
plus
were were on board with the with the
commission um it should be a post for
that reason
because again of the double standard but
also because
you absolutely know that this is going
to become a political which it's already
a political
witch hunt but a january 6 commission
that's all it's going to be
transparently it's going to be a
political witch-hunt
so uh republicans opposed it and that
that led to a lot of
stunned reactions by democrats or to
take it aback offended
stunned how how could you not be we were
we were under siege we were attacked
our lives were in jeopardy you don't
want to investigate this
more how dare you that was generally the
reaction summarizing
uh but representative tim ryan democrat
obviously from i think ohio
he uh they were all competing to
get on cable news and to have the most
self-righteous kind of
reaction but i think tim ryan managed to
take the cake let's
let's uh watch his performance gentlemen
uh
is recognized for 30 seconds i want to
thank the gentleman from new york and
the other republicans who are supporting
this and thank them for their
bipartisanship to the other 90 percent
of our friends on the other side of the
aisle
holy cow incoherence
no idea what you're talking about ben
gods that you guys
chased the former secretary of state all
over the country
spent millions of dollars we have people
scaling the capital
hitting the capitol police with lead
pipes across the head
and we can't get bipartisanship what
else has to happen in this country
cops this is a slap in the face to every
rank and file cop
in the united states if we're going to
take on china
if we're going to rebuild the country if
we're going to reverse climate change
we need two political parties in this
country that are both living in reality
and you ain't one of them i yield back
the balance of my time
well who then who what which political
party is living in reality
tim your political party is living in
reality
oh yeah uh one quick question can a man
get pregnant
i wish someone had had stood up and
asked like hey tim
uh you're living in reality over there
uh can you get pregnant
curious
just see what he says because they could
have asked him that hey tim can you
personally as a man are you able to get
pregnant
he would not be able to say no he
wouldn't be able to say no to that
i don't know you don't just say say
something like no i haven't tried
possible and that's that's living in
reality to him
i i have no interest in defending
republicans
you know they don't they have no
interest in defending themselves
so i'm not going to get up here all
angrily defending my side i don't even
consider republicans to be on my side
they're not on my side
um so it's not he could scream at
republicans all i want
all he wants i don't care
but the the idea the notion that
democrats are living in reality
and the great irony that he says that
right after
saying we need to reverse if we want to
reverse climate change
we need to live in reality uh what
you know tim because what is going to
prevent us from reversing climate change
is that we live in reality
and in reality you can't flip a switch
and control the weather
you can't reverse the climate you can't
you can't
come up with a government policy that's
going to change the weather you
maniac
uh oh that's that's reality too reality
two is that there's a policy that a
government could put in place
to change the weather to make hurricanes
go away
my god and uh and
it's delusion on top of delusion because
right before that
he's pretending to care about cops this
is an insult
to all of the rank and file police
officers
that i just decided to start caring
about
a couple of months ago but only in this
one instance
the democracy it is
really hard to watch
democrats pretend to care about cops
you want to talk about not living in
reality
yeah they they have found there is there
is
one there's just one okay
and test test me on this because find me
an example of another one but
as far as i can tell there is one dead
cop
there's only ever been one that these
scumbags have cared about and that was
officer from brian signick
and they cared about him because they
thought his death was useful to them and
then they stopped
caring when they discovered that oh
actually he died of natural causes and
wasn't killed by the rioters at all
so they for the the sliver of time when
they thought that
either they thought that the the riders
killed cynic or they thought they could
get away with pretending the writers
that killed him
that's when they cared that's it
there's a brief moment of time
when they cared about a dead cop
because there are thousands of other
dead cops that they've never said a word
about and don't give a damn about
and meanwhile tim ryan and all the rest
of them
they're out there telling people
that uh that that cops are trying to
track them down and kill them you know
this fantasy of of uh racist cops
hunting black men and murdering them in
the street
you think maybe that's an insult to the
rank and file how do you think the rank
of file feels about that
how do you think the rank of file police
officers feel every time one of them
is in a life or death struggle with an
assailant with a with a with a with a
criminal dirt bag and has to use lethal
force because they've been given no
choice
and they know that you are going to
throw them directly under the bus
accuse them of being a racist murderer
and do everything in your power to
destroy their lives and destroy their
families lives how do you think the rank
of file feel about that
i know how they feel because i hear from
them all the time off the record
and sometimes on the record
these people man completely shameless
and it's it's the scary thing is that
it's
almost convincing you you watch that and
if you had no frame of reference at all
and you watched that little uh spiel
from from tim ryan
you would almost think that he that he
really believes that he actually gives a
damn about cops
that he cares about reality
that he's really if he just wants
justice and he's offended that other
people aren't
on board with it you might believe it
if you didn't know any better
he's not a bad actor
[Music]
but the fact that they're such
convincing liars is what is uh so scary
not all of them are but but some of them
are well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content